a security camera captures the moment
two assassins open fire on a car on the
streets of Yangon
inside the deputy director of the Union
Election Commission killed in the attack
Security's been tight in myanmar's
largest city since the military coup in
2021 and incidents like this say the
military are the reason it can't
guarantee a return to electoral
democracy
speaking to Al Jazeera in late March the
spokesman conceded that as much as a
third of the country is not under gender
control it is
diff to say exactly when the general
elections will be held Our intention is
to include the whole country which is
what a system of free and fair
multi-party democracy means in order to
do that the voters and the candidates
must be absolutely safe without any
stress without any pressure or threats
but those voters will also have limited
choices at The Ballot Box this
unassuming building
at the national league for democracy
what was the party of government which
has now been dissolved but that leaves
an enormous problem for any elections
and the politics of Myanmar every
election that this party took part in
won an enormous landslide
recent changes in the registration
process allowed the union Election
Commission to dissolve 40 parties at the
end of March those parties that managed
to register have strong allegiances to
the military
and even they aren't hopeful a vote will
happen anytime soon
after the military coup we initially
estimated the general elections would be
held in mid-2023 the military said is
impossible for them to happen this year
even next year the earliest is likely to
be at the end of 2024.
those committed to Peaceful
demonstrations say they'll do everything
to disrupt the electoral process this
protest leader who asked to remain
anonymous believes that no democracy is
better than a flawed democracy it's the
same situation as in 1992 and 1993 if
the whole elections it means the forces
of democracy are defeated that's why we
are trying to stop the coming elections
the military is clearly in no hurry to
call elections and when it does the
polls will be on its terms but the
people of Myanmar also seem to have
little interest in a flawed electoral
process that'll do little to accelerate
a return to real democracy Tony Chang Al
Jazeera Yangon